so tell me about the seven million
dollar chain me what was that about know
what that was about that was about hey
listen it was almost like one of those
bug that I was down on my last seven I
couldn't find nothing else to invest in
the damn chain
[Music]
what's up me I'm good at man you I'm
doing well man I'm up here I mean
Newport Beach I'm with my crew here and
we having a ball
Knights Newport Beach Virginia
California California when you do that's
right y'all lucky man what's up with the
fire man it's not hot out there that's
why I had before 20 my brother how long
you been doing the podcast for I don't
know 18 months family I like it
hey it's pretty awesome to know why
because it really is just me Charlie
it's me I don't know it's me trying to
explain to people I really don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about but
still talking about you see some real
shitty life man for real I know you got
real stories what's going on I'm
beautiful Tyson cush man that old that's
right you got your farm going to
congratulations thank you so much thank
you
hopefully one time one day we don't have
anything to do yeah man we would love it
I can't wait to bring the kids
how old is your little one my smallest
one is seven no nine okay and the oldest
is 32 30 yeah yeah that's a nice range
man so what are you doing every day
besides the podcast just hang on baby
it's every day every day I'm working out
I'm getting up every day I'm doing my
all on my bike then I do it on my
treadmill weights and light weights you
still hitting backs I'm going there I'm
getting ready to go there another week
oh God so I mean do you think a normal
person can take a punch room I don't
know what is a normal person
like me like me like an odd athletic
type person it has nothing to do with
someone being honestly it has to do with
your morale uh-huh
no fighting a star that has nothing to
do finance or have to do with your
morality yeah and how you like giving
ferociousness know stand up to it and
take it no it's not about taking it is
about I don't know the willingness to
die that's what life is
uh-huh stand up and face that fire that
perspective then you don't have to fear
it that's really what we really don't
know who we are where we came from we
fail we don't know where we are who we
are we don't know if 10 down I need blue
black or green right that's crazy man so
what moment was it for you where you
knew that you could handle being a
fighter I never thought I can handle
being afraid is it just was and it
happened so do you I mean did you get
nervous before each fight or did you
have a point where you got pass on no
you always get nervous I'm nervous now
you get nervous that's just that's the
part of living life yeah actually
happens yeah yeah and just be like you
know [ __ ] it whatever happens happens I
believe it for my experience and I
believe that feeling of being what we
call scared or nervous it's some form of
natural defense mechanism uh-huh only
two things happen when you have that
feeling even um you rise to the occasion
or you just freeze well the only two
things that happen
you get squatted or you turn into the
predator you know your prey turn into
the predator it's just a weird
psychology isn't it
some guys
absolutely pounds and have that
mentality I'll oh that's great besides I
mean I talk about this a lot because I
get nervous still before we perform
shows and like you know that's the one
thing I've been doing all my life so you
would think that I would get past that
kind of you know reaction to every time
I got to perform in front of people but
you know different people say if you
really care you're gonna feel it every
time because you care about the outcome
of what's gonna happen so yeah I mean
it's just one of them Oh believe it or
not that no this is a small exponent of
our ego mm-hmm it's ego in challenging
ourselves yeah so you learn to let that
ego go and then you can kind of feel
free of that burden a little bit that's
what you're saying how do we let it go
really tell me the true how do we let it
show me that show me that enlightened
one that let it go yeah exactly I don't
know some people try to cope with you
know smoking weed or drinking or
whatever to try to like you know numb
that feeling or whatever but I don't
know exactly how you let it go at all
because it's a part of you yes and I
thought I can took the medicine I took
an ancient medicine once it was called
scarlet oh it's real ancient it's
probably hundreds of thousands of years
old it probably is always mankind's
medicine right and for instance my ego
was a nice no it wasn't at least I'm not
going to use that word my ego
disseminated so it happened very quickly
so when that happened no one had me and
had no idea well my gosh screams boom
the top of my lungs
like people were kicking my ass and I'm
that was the most frightening feeling
I've ever had in my life to the stand
never had a sibling that frightening
when I lost my ego crazy and I believe
that happen to everybody everybody will
be climbing on their needs afraid of
bugs
yeah thousand percent lamb because it's
almost a part of your self-identity is
your ego you know what I mean so if you
lose that you lose like sense itself and
you feel even more lost
you were before you know this is what I
just discovered about the ego the egos
of my my adopted the delusion of
yourself
it doesn't even but I go creates that
and that's what we fall in love with
that ego huh that's crazy
it protects you it's not good sometimes
the only our ego is only sometimes it
makes it it puts us in the glass ceiling
there's only go so [ __ ] the protector
from pushing ourselves further right
yeah it's gonna hurt him so he doesn't
want to feel my pain so he said don't do
it
right don't take that chance right now
holds us back and that's why we have to
let it go only for that moment but we
have to take it back don't ya yes yes
this part when it for a moment yeah I
need to learn some tips on how to part
with it you know what I'm saying
especially when I'm like going into you
know unfamiliar territories and [ __ ]
like that because I'm starting to do
stand-up comedy and that's not really
what I do I always grew up just being a
performer you know like on television or
in theater or whatever but the whole
like stand-up comedy like Dave Chappelle
and Eddie Murphy and Chris Rock and all
of that I never grew up in that
but since I've been doing comedy for so
long I'm starting to get pushed in today
me you understand that's so funny I mean
I would you know what your stand-up
comedian are so you do a formal standard
matter of fact I was watching you just
now when I was in the script with you
start with the form of stand-up right
there you're performing like you're a
stand-up they even over there
I'm sharpton invitation but that was a
form of stand-up yeah what's that we
can't do something because it wants to
hold us back because it doesn't want to
work hard right train is your work once
all along all the pledges from it wants
to say hey I did this I've done this
I've done that right without having to
do to work got to do to work no way
around it you want to build up a solid
body and a solid defense system you got
to do the work probably you know
I'm 41 about to be 42 think about dying
yeah I mean once you start having kids
you think about that you know what I
mean look at your kids you see
immortality yeah a thousand percent oh
you see what life would be like once I'm
gone you know or just start imagining
those kinds of things you know as life
goes on and they go on through their
life you start realizing that you can't
really be there the whole time you know
what I'm saying that they're there and
you just count the blessings of the days
that you are there I guess how do you
look at your children and your wife do
you believe that they're yours what do
you believe that you're working to make
something else worth or you believe that
my wife either my kid they listen to
what I say how does that work
nah I don't think of you you know I look
at them like they belong to me
necessarily like not at all I know you
know lots of different things can happen
at any given moment in life so I can't
like act like I have control over all
those aspects I look at it more like I'm
blessed to be around them in whatever
situation has caused me to be that I'm
you know my wife's husband on my
children's father and that's you know
the situation that I've been placed in
in their lives basically so I'm just
looking at it as a blessing leave we'll
be involved everybody's passing
universes cross for that reason the
other thing that I was looking my
children and myself I looked at my
mother in my vessel yeah I mean that's
what they say
and we seen Karen and from other people
yeah I mean that's what they say talking
to my tassel is my wife right here come
through you they don't come you know
from you necessary so yeah I've always
felt like you know my parents were
definitely a vessel for
my kids it is a blessing to be able to
witness this you know like my part is
done I think you know I'm here for more
life support but as far as like me
trying to tell them what's gonna happen
you know you know what they need to be
doing more of an assistant coach as
opposed to give aim you know I mean
absolutely 100% I'm still I still juggle
with them dealing with my children their
personality their you have somebody and
you love them it's unbelievable I mean
you say hey what the hell is that come
from
you know after you say you say I don't
know I mean like you trying to tell you
[Laughter]
I'm telling you like you can't choose
the kind of personality you can't come
out
[Music]
[Music]
you okay she's okay yeah man life is
beautiful man I'm a blessed individual
you are too late there's totally
grateful I'm totally grateful of listen
I was very grateful at the worst of my
life I've never not been grateful yeah
so tell me about the seven million
dollar chain me what was that about
hey I don't know what that was about
that was about hey listen it was almost
like one of those drug dealers I was
down in my last seven I can't find
nothing else to invest in but damn chain
straight up you got it huh
you still got the chain oh no I guess my
wife got that in the divorce
yeah that's one of the things things to
experience that I'm so happy to
experience a life that I had to come
from like a brothel to be Who I am now
I'm so happy with my life and after
they're absolutely Brella firm like an
outside perspective watching your life
landings like your stoppable but I've
seen you go from you know the ultimate
highs to some would say ultimate lows to
right back to highs again you know what
I mean just because you're so persisted
in being true to yourself number one and
I think that's when people love from you
know I get the most one of the most
genuine celebrity-type people that there
ever has been you know you're just some
real individualism that will always I
think continue to take a forward you
know opportunities for you to make money
on that you know what I'm saying so I
think that's a beautiful thing I can
only admire somebody whose brand is so
true to themselves that they can't be
stopped it's a it's a real force hey you
think that way about me and stuff
and at this stage of my life this is
really inches on I'm to feed that well
because I
like now and i'm license they're all
about less now my whole life was about
being a glutton that now is all about
less yeah and then I'm looking some of
the spiritual books or stuff that we
have too much stuff we don't even share
it we don't really use it but we want to
share it and give it to the right I'm in
the hundreds of thousand dollar stuff to
have a 110 years yeah yeah I mean you
know someone stuff yeah the beauty of it
is that you got time to figure out what
you do with it you know and like I feel
like the Mike Tyson museum it's gonna be
an awesome destination once we get that
up and running you know thinking about
that you should be because your life has
been on I'm having my car they need to
go to some people that need that stuff
way too much money
ya know you know hey we don't need to
invest in mothballs give that [ __ ] away
they got Salvation Army around I'm sure
I was so I was so uh I would throw up I
was such a good swimmers I used to
consume everything I had did I would
how's the plan that for the stupid
people are the consumers are the stupid
people I learned that lately and had to
be the most dad I 2,000 years ago to
find that out that's what I'm saying but
you think that comes from growing up
without yeah so once you get it you want
to start getting everything you ever
even dreamed of and then those dreams
are coming true the fact that you can
buy - yes you start buying more [ __ ] if
stuff I never use yeah you don't even
one yeah I got caught up with being in
the consumer world I was one of those
guys that quite caught up it didn't it
didn't appear that well with packaged
different but I was still that rat
running around in that little thing with
a little wheel yeah being that guy but I
was just a guy on a big level but you
couldn't see them unless you it's so
funny because a lot of the image we have
of you is still just with the black
trunks you know I'm saying in the black
shoes just ready no I'm saying no robe
no none of that just straight coming in
and getting ready to business so I
people weren't able to see that other
side of your life you know so it's it's
interesting to hear you talk about like
being such a consumer because your
presence when you come to fight was just
you know down and dirty you know what
I'm saying like I don't need nothing but
these gloves and these shorts and I said
I don't need no hoop line or none of
that
well for that I needed to be that guy I
couldn't be that guy in society you know
amazing yeah that's so cool man so where
do you live live now
in California and then the Newport Beach
and also in Las Vegas Nevada yeah I'm
just
I think Newport Beach is really awesome
another one to live up here before but I
have friends that always lived up here
yeah told me that I do I need to I need
to turn Republican and move up here and
I'm living up here this is the place to
be I think should have been I see no
Darla's my friend told me to come up
here I mean [ __ ] Orange County super
nice land and Newport is like the
license part of it so you're living well
I'm happy for you
yeah I make fun about the people up here
yeah I know I did
beautiful yeah I mean the way people
vote is one thing but when you I to I
with somebody that's what the real
connection is so I think you're in a
good pocket of people man you'll be
fired into the sin I love Vegas - man I
lived out and Henderson for like four
years
Graham Hill and Seven Hills complex yeah
I live in Lake Las Vegas was awesome
yeah yeah so you remember good doing
what's up with that on the show I don't
remember those is my big nose my big
cocaine you know what's happening your
perspective when you're on it I said
I've never really I've never done it so
I don't really know like what the
experience is like you just like step
outside of yourself when your honor and
you can't remember what's going on No
most of you know it's an eagle silk drug
most most drugs that inflate your ego
that they're debilitating drugs their
drugs are gonna eventually kill you
and tell you tell you huh you know um
medicine or drugs that you use that
stripped you from your ego is medicine
that heals you in that fertile II how
that works
Hey right and that's nature telling you
that's not nobody with a PhD that's
nature that's Carla telling you that
right there nobody bigger than that no
doubt about it and a heel creditor Lord
also has a strange way of making you a
believer - yeah whether you want to or
like 100%
yeah so what's going on man what's the
plans
what's the plan for the Tyson farms
what's the plan for and sky's the limit
when I'm when God ready to let them run
the virus let's see no we get maybe
going at it again and we're going to
open up on Tyson Tyson Ranch Resort all
over the country and like I said man
who's going sky's the limit this is
something I always wanted but never knew
I wanted to it's something listen I've
learned to miss my skin's and being on
my partner's up there sometimes we
forgot what we forgot we forgot yeah you
know and it just comes to play when you
know you're around the right energy and
the right people and they think the same
perspective that you think about the
world
no doubt so what do you look forward to
the most when you wake up in the morning
excuse me so what do you look forward to
the most when you wake up in the morning
just existing yes dehr advantage of that
moment of the day thanking God for
waking up kiss my wife make love to my
wife smack my son in the head kiss my
daughter tell my mother-in-law I love
our house my father-in-law go outside
get to the office come to my partner we
love each other we make deal the day is
over easy go to dinner I was go back
home didn't come back saying the
everything and it's persistent we'll be
doing a paper math we're very persistent
in care they're not always motivated the
consistency kicks motivation there's a
thousand percent a thousand percent yeah
I did that man like I feel almost the
same way exactly you know like I look
forward to seeing those baby smiled like
even if I'm you know dead tired and it's
like [ __ ] I'm not ready to wake up as
soon as I look over and then babies and
smiling at me it's like well here comes
a brand new day and I'm thankful for it
so yeah I look at my children know what
I don't care how big my ego get how much
money I manage made at times and stuff
when I look at my children they make me
feel where my mortality yeah yeah lucky
you know absolutely you're lucky to see
what it is when you seeing it at the
time yeah grandchild now we go hold on
to you man hold on you like Morgan
Freeman you know he's a great great
granddaddy out there he'll be really
yeah man he's stressed out no electric
company come on man between him and
Laurence Fishburne on those like
learning shows Laurence was on Peter
Hurley yeah or that DB Herman - yeah
crazy I love it man well I mean I'm not
gonna hold you all day brother I just
wanted to thank you very much for coming
on with
it's my pleasure man anytime and you
know I started yeah some people were
telling me who me yeah I got it my
sitcom is coming hopefully you know it's
called Kenan Kenan and what is the
synopsis of it I'm widowed father
raising two young girls basically okay
yeah and like I have like a morning show
in Atlanta like a like a you know Ryan
Seacrest and Kelly type show and yeah
I'm trying to raise my babies you know
dealing with that kind of late in life
but I'm gonna learn how to do it yeah so
we got to get you on the show brother
whenever you want yeah I started a
podcast too so I want to get you to come
on and see if I could take you need from
anybody
absolutely I love you brother thank you
absolutely man thank you whoo talk soon
love